je suis son frère mais je suis aussi son
agent je suis son producteur suit son
avocat ce sont deux chauffeurs jeu son
garde du corps de sa mère dès fois merci
c'est tout pour moi c'était j'aimerais
faire venir une personne sur scène
quelqu'un qui compte beaucoup pour moi
qui a qui me donne confiance qui m'est
aussi des gros coup de pression des fois
mais sans qui ce spectacle n'aurait
jamais existé
non
[Applaudissements]
je venais mourad cellule comité famille
photo so you
ouais
rappaz a passé de nouveaux achats fabien
auquel va venir s'installer ici je suis
à te prendre mon projet prend mal c'est
normal tu veux construire
combien de places déjà ici 6200 et vous
disent que ça je peux faire un sketch
mais c'est celui du téléphone portable
voici les gages maintenant ta gueule toi
ta gueule c'est très bien tout de même
de passage et c'est tout je reste a
raconté experts nous ont dit pas exprès
mais je dois quand même retrouve une
place pour mon frère doit-on en vie
parce que la famille saini un jour ou
l'autre ça crée des problèmes
je sais pas si c'est un mec qui me veut
vraiment du bien ou si c'est un type qui
cherchent un parpaing fermeture
c'est pas forcément contre les ennemis
ses poils les ennemis c'est ce qu'on
aime le plus
notamment à tous que j'ai pas servis
soit responsable abandonné
[Musique]
n'oublie pas que tu as réussi c'est
grâce à moi
n'oublie pas ça
[Musique]